so the space jockeys just like the worst
pilots ever how many of these ships are
just littered across the galaxy so the
latest trailer for alien covenant and
now I've talked a little bit about this
thing before mainly about how much I did
not like before Australia's I came out
they came out with a little bit of a
thing a week or so ago that they this
clip that they called the Last Supper
that shows the crew and you know them
interacting before things I'll go to
heck and I didn't do a video on that but
I consider doing I didn't really care
for that either it wasn't bad there was
something wrong with it it just it felt
so much like they were just trying to
recapture the dynamics of that original
crew from the original movie and for me
at least it didn't help that they call
back to you know somebody started
coughing and you know somebody even said
the line come on the foods not that bad
which is direct lift from aioli and I
know it's supposed to be a homage or an
easter egg or whatever for me it just it
just highlighted how much of a retread
that whole thing felt so that didn't
impress me this trailer I'm not going to
say it gets rid of my fears and my lack
of faith and this will be entirely but
is better it's better on a lot of levels
mostly because it spends the first chunk
not focusing on the overt horror
elements and as much as I love alien as
a horror film that first one especially
you know it it's really hard to sell a
horror movie on Don those kinds of
things because we've seen all before
when you do it in trailer editing it
kind of all looks the same but what they
showed for what looks like the earlier
from the set of stuff actually intrigued
me and for a lot of like small reasons
and those small reasons could end up
being the thing that puts it into a more
favorable thing or they could be small
things that aren't big enough to
actually make up a difference for things
that I don't like we'll see but some of
the small things I like they mentioned
that the crew is made up of couples and
I hadn't realized that I know that they
were colonists you know going to a
planet but I didn't realize that it was
made up of couples people who are
intentionally together now that's a
small thing but that's actually a
significant difference from pretty much
any other space movie that you see
because maybe there's one couple going
on but nine times out of ten they're not
supposed to be fraternizing in the first
place and the other times if I as I said
it's like just one couple of usually
having just some sort of wild sex bling
going on so the idea that these people
are repent because of their bonds
together and that to me actually add
some more stakes to it that these aren't
people who are just stuck in a tin can
and hooked up because that's the only
person there that that they felt
attracted to know these are people who
actually genuinely care about each other
well ahead of anything going wrong and I
think if played well that could really
bring a lot more weight and stakes too
when characters inevitably start getting
picked off if they play it right
certainly it's a setup I appreciate it
there is another thing just about the
moment when they're there on the planet
and there's a part of me that feels like
God you know they just say just picked a
really pretty areum's I look at the
daily plate if it looks so much like
Earth but then they you know they
mentioned good you know this is weak
this is weird and that ended up itself
felt like you know kind of hanging a
lampshade on the problem but then the
other thing you know do you hear
anything there's no animals and the more
I thought about it the more thought
that's kind of interestingly oddly
creepy and unnerving the idea that you
could be this place that looks like
Earth but there's no other sounds I just
think of the ambient sounds when you're
out in nature the buzz of insects you
know things like birds you know
something moving in a bush all that
stripped out and gone that's oddly
creepy I'm not sure how effectively it
can be conveyed in a movie that seems
like the kind of creepy that would work
much better you know as a as an actual
experience or maybe a like in a video
game but it's it's an idea that i like
um so there's sort of those little
things but then you know they have the
facehugger jump
then we get into the rapid cut here's
bits of gore here's a kill years and
here's a xenomorph bashing his head on
the windshield and all that was fine
that was sort of where it can lose me
but nothing that i saw on that back half
of the trailer did anything to change
much of my mind it just reminded me of
the stuff that i seen before but what
they showed in terms of the setup and on
the front half of that trailer intrigued
me much more and i'm hoping that it's
indicative not just of them going and
here's our Father like I would like to
see them put some effort into this
setting and into these characters and I
think these little touches that I
mentioned might point to them doing that
they also just might be fluff and they
don't add up to anything but it's the
first thing really since the title
change from prometheus 2 22 alien
covenant that to me has been a positive
thing that I've seen because it seems
like ever since that title change
everything that I've seen every trailer
every image or whatever it's just been
my enthusiasm for the parties are just
going yeah and this is brought it back
up a little me not where it started when
I first heard there was going to be a
follow-up to prometheus but it's it's
not continuing to dip and that's not
nothing I just really don't want it to
abandon the big ideas that Prometheus
was trying to tackle Prometheus didn't
completely succeed at what I was doing
but I liked its ambition and I want to
see this be a movie with ambition not
just a let's let's just do alien flash
or [ __ ] space stuff again because we've
seen it we've seen it done awesome and I
would rather see them try to pay off the
bigger ideas from prometheus and while
the things that I saw the friend don't
necessarily point to that they point to
more thought and care being laid into
the film then I initially would have
given it credit for so we'll see what
happens so those are my thoughts on the
latest trailer for alien covenant did
you see the trailer what were your
thoughts on it whatever they were drop
something down
let's talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter I
council geeks give a listen to the
counsel of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned